so the last few videos we've essentially
done an overview of benjamin franklin's
entire life and there's a people want to
go in more depth there's a very good
biography about it
which i encourage people to read
actually is is fascinating but you know
just big picture takeaways what what are
the lessons for from ben franklin well
first of all he was a renaissance man of
the enlightenment which was cool he
loved science as well as writing in the
humanities he was our best scientist
inventor diplomat he was a good business
strategist the first rags the richest
person he's also the person who invents
i think the essential american character
which is being proudly middle class
being proud to be a shopkeeper as he put
it a member of the leather apron club
who gets up every morning puts on the
leather apron and helps fellow citizens
he also knew that the backbone of
america was going to be a shopkeeping
class who formed civic organizations
that brought people together
you know that's why he forms all these
things like the libraries and the
hospitals and the academies and that
sort of thing
and also it he has a notion of tolerance
we were very ethnic people in the
colonies
up until philadelphia rises and
philadelphia is the first city that has
everything from anglicans and moravians
and jews and quakers and freed slaves
and indians and franklin as a shopkeeper
becomes an apostle of tolerance saying
it's if we help bring people together
and tolerate everybody's beliefs and
religions and backgrounds that's going
to be the secret sauce of america's
diversity and you know you see it
throughout his life you need
wonderful passionate people like john
and sam adams if you're gonna have a
great country and you need revered
people like george washington but you
also need the people who say our
strength will come from bringing us
together from our diversity over and
over again when he creates a civic
organization the motto will be
things like the good we can do together
is greater than all the goods we can do
separately and to pull forth benefits
for the common good is divine that's
engraved on the hospital
he does the first editorial cartoon
called join or die which was about the
colonies they all have to get together
yeah and join or die and when he goes to
albany in the 1750s to bring the
colonies together so that they aren't
you know sort of a catholic colony of
maryland and a puritan colony of
massachusetts we're all one country with
uh religiously diverse
and finally i'll go to the end of his
life because it seems symbolic at that
time after he brings people together at
the constitutional convention and
everything else
i realized that during his lifetime he
donated to the building fund of each and
every church built in philadelphia
at one point they were building a
new hall during the great awakening when
preachers used to ride around america
and preach and they wanted a hall in
philadelphia that a visiting preacher
could preach at and benjamin franklin
writes a fundraising document it says
even if the mufti of constantinople were
to send somebody to preach
islam to us and to teach us about the
prophet muhammad we should offer a
pulpit and listen before we may learn
something
and on his deathbed that's this is in 17
yeah this is in the 17
70s he's very religiously tolerant
and on his deathbed i looked at the
ledgers of this he's the largest
individual contributor to the mikvah
israel synagogue
the first synagogue built in
philadelphia so when he dies
instead of his minister accompanying his
casket to the grave
all 35 ministers preachers and priests
of philadelphia linked arms with the
rabbi of the jews for this huge funeral
procession
that marched with him to the grave
it was that type of
tolerance
freedom
belief that we could all live together
despite our different backgrounds
that was what they were fighting for
what they created
in 1776 and in 1787
when they create the united states and
it is still the essential thing that the
united states is fighting for
both around the world but also at home
to keep that legacy of ben franklin
alive